JONATHAN: Well, good
afternoon, and welcome
to "Musicians at Google."
Yeah, our inaugural show.
This is so exciting.
Thanks so much for
coming out to share this.
This is Hollie
Cook's first US tour.
I'm going to go
way out on a limb
here and predict it will
be far from her last.
Hollie is absolutely amazing.
You will find that out
in the next few minutes
if you don't already know it.
Her band is tight and smoking.
This is going to be
an incredible show.
They're at the very
beginning of their US tour.
We saw them last
night at the Paradise.
It sounded like they've been
on the road for weeks already.
Just unbelievable.
Please join me in welcoming
Hollie Cook and the band.
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: Hello.
Thank you for having us.
I'm going to start
with a song that
was my first single
from my first album.
It's called "That Very Night."
[MUSIC HOLLIE COOK, "THAT VERY
NIGHT"]
HOLLIE COOK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: Thank
you very much.
I'm going to do
another old song.
It's the first song that
I recorded as Hollie Cook.
It's called "Milk and Honey."
[MUSIC HOLLIE COOK, "MILK AND
HONEY"]
HOLLIE COOK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: So I released
a new album this year.
So I'm going to play a
couple of songs from that.
This song is called "99."
It's about
[INAUDIBLE], actually.
[MUSIC -- HOLLIE COOK, "99"]
HOLLIE COOK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: Got one more song.
So I'll just sing it.
It's called "Looking
for Real Love."
It's also from my new album.
Thank you very much
for coming and sharing.
You're great critics.
Thank you very much to Jonathan
and the crew in front of us.
And also thank you to the
Next Level Band [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: This song is
called "Looking for Real Love."
I've been Hollie
Cooke from London.
[MUSIC HOLLIE COOK, "LOOKING FOR
REAL LOVE"]
[APPLAUSE]
HOLLIE COOK: Thank
you very much, Google.
JONATHAN: Hollie, we
all know you by name.
But Next Level Band, do you want
to tell everybody your name?
We don't know you, yet.
JAIME HINCKSON: Sure.
My name is Jaime Hinckson.
I play keys for Hollie Cook.
JARED MEEKER: I'm Jared Meeker.
I play guitar.
PATRICK BAILEY: Patrick Bailey.
I play bass.
BLAKE COLLIE: Blake Collie.
I play drums.
JONATHAN: So you guys
are all from LA, correct?
And you've played together for
a while now on other projects?
BLAKE COLLIE: We
played-- these two guys,
we played off and
on since '96 or so.
This guy over here
on keyboard just
got to LA through a mutual
friend, and hit it off.
And here we are to
instantly jump in
on the adventure with Hollie.
JONATHAN: Wow,
that's outstanding.
How did you hook up?
HOLLIE COOK: How did we?
We worked together
earlier this year
when I played in California,
and I've worked with Patrick
before last year when
I played in California.
And then-- they all just--
they all know each other.
And it was--
BLAKE COLLIE: It was Warren at
Sierra Nevada, recommended--
I'm in a group in LA.
A reggae band in LA
called The Lions.
And Warren, who-- what's
Warren's last name?
HOLLIE COOK: Smith.
BLAKE COLLIE: Smith.
Yeah, Warren Smith
recommended The Lions
because she had an LA show.
And so we got to do a
festival date with her.
And then a show in LA,
and then I stayed in touch
with Hollie, and with
David, and here we are.
JONATHAN: Wow, perfect.
Wow.
Great.
Well, I won't welcome
you all to the US
since you live
here, but Hollie--
Hollie, welcome to the US.
HOLLIE COOK: Yeah, thank you.
JONATHAN: Welcome to Boston.
Welcome to Google.
So great to have you here.
HOLLIE COOK: It's a pleasure.
I'm excited.
JONATHAN: You do come from
a family that's probably
more interesting than most
of the people in this room.
HOLLIE COOK: I don't
know if that's true.
JONATHAN: Well, I don't know.
If you're not entirely
sick of talking about it,
could you talk a little
bit about your family?
HOLLIE COOK: My family is cool.
My mom was a singer
later on in her life,
and she grew up with Boy George.
And was around when he
formed culture club,
so she was backing vocalist
for a little while.
Until it got crazy,
and I think she
decided that it was
not really her calling.
To be in a huge pop band.
So she change direction.
But my father has always been
a musician, and still is.
He's a drummer.
He's Paul Cook, and he
played in the Sex Pistols.
It's kind of normal.
JONATHAN: If you grew up
that way, it would be.
Sure.
HOLLIE COOK: It's my normal.
He's very cool.
They both-- I owe all
of my musical ability
to both my parents.
More the singing
from my mom, but it's
been an interesting ride.
And they've been
extremely supportive.
That's been the coolest part.
Is that they've always
totally understood
where I was coming from.
So aside from a few
disappointing school dropouts,
or whatever, they
were like it's OK.
You're clearly taking
this seriously enough.
JONATHAN: Well, that's great.
Did they encourage
you to go into music,
or was it something that you
just naturally gravitated to?
HOLLIE COOK: They just
saw that it was something
that I was leaning towards
from a really young age.
And they did-- they
got me piano lessons,
and I had dance lessons
when I was a kid.
They never pushed it on me.
They just could see straight
away that it was something
that I was most likely
going to end up doing.
So they encouraged it.
JONATHAN: And how did you tend
to gravitate toward reggae?
HOLLIE COOK: Just the way
that you do, I suppose.
I was a teenager, and I had
a few records here and there.
And it was just-- it just had
something special about it
that I wanted to be
apart of in a way.
I was singing in a band called
The Slits for about five years,
and they've got a very
strong reggae influence
in their music.
So from performing
with them, I kind of
got deeper into the reggae vibe.
And I met a producer
called Prince Fatty, who
I've worked with
on both my records.
And once I met him, it kind
of all fell into place.
And it felt like a
very true way for me
to express myself musically.
And I stuck with it
because it felt good.
JONATHAN: Reggae nicknames
are the best nicknames.
I wish I had something
like Prince Fatty to go by.
Really, but I'll
have to work on that.
So the band-- have you
been playing reggae
mostly yourselves, or is that
just one of several styles
that you've worked on?
JARED MEEKER: We've been playing
a lot of different styles,
and I speak for everybody
here in saying that.
But reggae-- I've been
playing with Blake here
for-- since we were 20 years
old, or something like that.
So we've been doing
it for a while.
And when we were
first starting out
we were lucky to open up for
a lot of big name reggae acts,
and certainly got our feet wet.
And that left a lasting
impression on us.
So that was a huge
influence in how
we think about reggae,
and in some ways
every other genre
of music that we
play has a little
bit of reggae in it.
Like naturally, you know?
There's certainly a
little bit of unity
that you can hear within
every style of music.
It's like a through
line, but reggae
is something that's really
close to our hearts for sure.
JONATHAN: Wow.
Excellent.
Yeah, the sound is amazing.
It really is.
I mean it's-- it's
clearly reggae.
There's no mistaking that.
But with your vocals, there's
just really nothing like it
in my opinion.
Really completely special.
HOLLIE COOK: Thank you.
JONATHAN: Speaking of
your parents, there maybe
some people here who've
heard of the Sex Pistols.
There may be some
people who think
that "Never Mind the Bollocks,
Here's the Sex Pistols"
is one of the greatest
albums recorded
in the second half
of the 20th century.
So if you want to pass that on
to your dad, that'd be fine.
HOLLIE COOK: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN: There may be people
who also watched the Karma
Chameleon video once a month
whether they need to or not.
So You could pass
that on to your mom.
HOLLIE COOK: I will.
That'll make them smile.
JONATHAN: OK.
Well that's great.
People have not forgotten.
So your tour just kicked off a
couple nights ago in Brooklyn.
You were in Boston last night.
You're doing the East coast
here, and for how long?
HOLLIE COOK: We've
got two more dates
in Philadelphia
and Washington, DC.
And then we fly over
to the West coast
and start in Boulder, Colorado,
and drive down through.
So we're going to Seattle,
Portland, Oakland, and Los
Angeles.
JONATHAN: OK.
HOLLIE COOK: So it's a mini-tour
for now being my first time
here.
We'll do all the
stuff in the middle
hopefully at some
other point, I suppose.
If there's an interest for it.
JONATHAN: Yeah, I
think the American
Midwest needs to
hear your music.
HOLLIE COOK: It's a big place,
so it takes a lot of time
to travel around
the whole thing.
So, yeah, we'll keep it
East and West for now,
and then we'll see what
happens in the future.
JONATHAN: OK.
So "Twice" is still pretty
new-- your second CD.
Are you working on any
material for a third CD,
or is the tour
keeping you too busy?
HOLLIE COOK: The
tour's keep me busy.
I've been touring all
summer, but it's always--
I can't tell which
parts my favorite,
but I do love the
touring aspects of it,
and traveling around is one
of the most inspiring things.
So it helps with the process
of writing new material.
So there's stuff
in the pipeline.
I don't have any plans for
a third album just yet.
Like a whole album.
I'm scared of the commitment.
So I'll probably do
some short projects,
and then make an album
in a couple of years.
Or maybe I'll surprise
myself, and there'll
be an album within
the next year.
Who knows.
I'd like to keep it
interesting by having
absolutely no plans whatsoever.
JONATHAN: Well we'll
prepare to be delighted
whichever way you go.
JARED MEEKER: By
the way, Jonathan.
There is a reggae name
generator that you can just
go-- I'm sure with Google being
here, you guys know about that.
But if you go type in
Jonathan, and you'll
get-- Ross John, or
something like that.
JONATHAN: Excellent.
Thank you for that.
Thanks.
There's a lot of days
where I really need that.
You have no idea.
So give me the URL.
I'll do it this afternoon.
Oh, a question from that
young lady in the audience.
Do you want to come up here
and-- because otherwise we
won't be able to hear you.
AUDIENCE: I spent some
time in the Midwest,
and my favorite reggae
bar was The Wild Hare
and Singing Armadillo Frog
Sanctuary in Wrigleyville.
It's closed now, but I
think there's probably
a pretty good scene there.
So I would encourage
you to go to Chicago.
But I also wonder where
is the reggae scene?
Are you going to pop
venues, or is there
sort of that subculture of
reggae music in the bar scene?
BLAKE COLLIE: The majority
of-- the strongest parts
in the United States--
of the reggae scene--
would probably be,
historically, New
York at the top of the list.
Just for Jamaican families to
come and set up shop early on,
like in the '50s and
'60s and whatnot.
Between the New York, and
then over to LA in particular.
It could be due to the weather.
And then Miami.
The guy right here can
tell you about Miami.
But those three would
be the strongest.
And then, interestingly
enough, in California-- it's
referred to as West
coast by some people,
but California mainly.
There's a California
roots reggae
scene that we're
all coming from,
and a part of the
different bands.
The Lions, The Expanders,
The Aggrolites.
Then there's reggae rock groups
like Revolution and Tribal
Seeds.
So there's a whole huge, huge
scene over on the West coast.
And so now, as it spreads from
LA up to Seattle and back down,
the main gist of LA and, or
Southern California and Miami
is certainly the weather.
Which I will let
this guy take over.
And then, from
where Holly's from,
would be the other
biggest area in the world
outside of Jamaica.
It's just in the UK in
Brixton and places like that.
Again, historically,
really, really famous reggae
bands-- Steel Pulse to Aswad.
Groups like that
come from that area.
So for what we're doing
here in the States,
that's the great
thing about this tour.
Is we're hitting some
of these primary--
I should include Colorado too.
You guys can maybe
figure out why
Colorado might like
reggae so much.
So, with that said, you
can fill in the Miami void.
JAIME HINCKSON: Well, yeah.
I was born and raised in Miami,
but my family's from Jamaica.
Jamaica used to be under
British rule, which
is why England has
so much reggae music.
But reggae is such a
revolutionary genre.
I could sit here and
name artists off the top
my head for days, but
you guys know them.
Because reggae is
so revolutionary.
It's very international.
It's not specific to one city.
Of course there's a lot
of Jamaican influence,
Caribbean influence in
Miami because it's so close.
Everybody originally--
like my parents--
they migrated to New York.
So a big influence there, and
of course Denver and California
for obvious reasons.
But reggae is everywhere.
There's reggae festivals
all over the world,
and eventually we're going to
end up playing in all of them.
[MOCKING EVIL LAUGH]
JONATHAN: I guess we're all set.
I wanted to thank
you again for coming
to visit us and play with us.
That was an incredible set.
You guys sounded amazing.
Not a surprise.
HOLLIE COOK: It was
an absolute pleasure.
It's very cool to be here.
JONATHAN: Wonderful
to have you here,
and best of luck on
the rest of your tour
and whatever comes next.
HOLLIE COOK: Thank you so much.
And cheers for coming.
JONATHAN: OK.
BLAKE COLLIE: Thanks
for having us.
[APPLAUSE]